[Music]
you know we have a lot of fun on the
show but we also like to help uh our
fans help our audience and a lot of
people in our audience use craigslist
let's face it a lot of you are on
craigslist and i thought we'd help our
audience members uh make a sale or
connection by showing some of their
craigslist ads right here on the program
right now all right
this could be fun
let's check them out first up
for sale
75 pounds of styling gel buyer must
extract from my hair
is this one recycle i can personally
crush your soda cans with my forehead
for sale the wallet of the guy sitting
next to me
[Applause]
he still has no idea
wanted kids to go on my lawn why so i
can yell at you to get the hell off of
it
great opportunities for attractive young
women send photo to don't worry it's not
humantrafficking.net
[Applause]
wanted dude to provide alibi for the
night of april 4th from 7 p.m to 2 a.m
must be able to convince my wife that we
were night golfing
wanted someone to post positive reviews
about my mustache on yelp stash it's
yelp for mustaches okay this was just an
ad free yelp stash
and finally
realize your ultimate fantasy as long as
your ultimate fantasy is watching a
doctor who marathon then helping me
bathe my mom
you're welcome